once the adapter is initialized let's
bind it to the ListView but you may
notice that we don't have a reference to
the list view in our fragment it was
only defined in the layout XML the
system takes and inflates layout XML
files and turns them into a full view
hierarchy with the route layout of the
main activity at the very top of the
view tree we can also assign IDs to each
view in the tree but it's not required
if you don't need a reference to an
individual view for example this image
view doesn't have an ID associated with
it and that's okay within the Java code
of The Associated activity or fragment
if we need a reference to the button we
can simply call find view by ID which
will traverse down the view hierarchy
until it finds a view with the ID button
and then it will return that similarly
we can traverse down a view hierarchy to
find the linear layout with the ID
container and then return that we could
do the same to find a reference to this
textview by traversing down the view
hierarchy but you'll notice that we
already have a reference to the
container which is the direct parent of
this textview hence we can just call
container defined view by ID to search
this subtree to find the textview with
this ID and then return it with this
method we have a smaller subtree to
search for a given view as opposed to
searching the entire view hierarchy in
the Android Java dock for the view class
which is linked below if you want to
follow along it contains an example
where the button was define in layout
XML it was assigned an ID my button then
in the activity we can use the find view
by ID method with that ID so that we can
get a reference to the button then we
can change it dynamically such as by
adding a click listener to it now in the
placeholder fragment class find the
adapter to the ListView luckily we did
assign an ID to the ListView earlier so
we can find it easily now think about
the smallest subtree in the view
hierarchy that you can call find view by
ID on then set the adapter on it if you
want an example you can see one in the
link below check the boxes when you're
done